Charlie Rolly he asked for that meeting
and he met to resume he had a long
conversation on that matter
and since British media and also the
government put the blame on Russia as
far as the souls were concerned and they
Eames they were concerned so I decided
that I have to explain the position of
the Russian Federation which is a little
bit different from the position of the
British government but if Russia and
we've heard this explanation a lot over
the last year Russia had nothing to do
with it why did you agree to meet him
why didn't you say well go to the go to
the French Embassy go to some other
embassy because they had as much to do
to it with it as us well what the rich
media is not writing about the French
Embassy they are writing about the
Russian embassy that's why you know I
thought that they have to get the the
explanations at least you know at the
point of view from the first hand
charlie was he was really surprised to
hear a lot of things 80% of what I said
to him he never heard of what you think
were the tallying points well the first
thing is that a year passed and we
didn't have any official report of the
investigation so this is just a fact of
life and we're still waiting for that
report second I showed him diplomatic
notes that we sent to Foreign Office
it's something around 70 of them and
never we never got the reply to them so
all the questions that were put on
Salisbury most the Salisbury of course
the win every flies but we have the
outstanding facts about Salisbury know
which even you can't deny there were two
Russian men there at the very time that
the screep hearts were poisoned now you
may deny that they were in the GRU and
that Navi chalk was used which was
originally developed in Russian
laboratories first of all there are no
proofs that it was developed in the
Russian labs you know the first thesis
of the resume was that was done in
Russia and that's why Russia is guilty
so now we have proofs that that
so-called novel joke could be produced
in any place in Europe so the thesis of
the prime minister this Russia is the
only place and fortune is not supported
by the facts
so this is how the coincidence the
coincidence of two GRU offices being
sightseeing in Salisbury on the same day
that's the story of the of the British
press and also the government but
unfortunately it's not supported by the
fact first of all they give me an
interview in the Russian television and
they so said officially they are not
part of the GRU this is first and second
the British side could have an
opportunity to question them but they
were never asked for that
if you know the the Russian side would
be asked for that we will help you to
consider so the bridge is going to drop
mr. ambassador so the British side the
British yes can question these two men
if they would ask for requests from the
Foreign Office will allow them to be
questioned yeah we were ready to
consider but the request never appeared
there was no request why well why do you
think I don't know I don't know because
the people I mean these two people they
said on the Russian TV officially they
had nothing to do with this Salisbury
case that was their statement they also
said officially they have nothing to do
with the GRU in the British side refused
to cooperate with Russia on any anything
in Salisbury so we simply do not
understand the position of the British
girl you'll be aware of the
investigative website bearing caps which
did some exchange that were the
exhaustive research and and confirmed
them as members of the GRU and a
potential third member as well the
problem is that this as we know it's
connected with the British intelligence
so there is no trust to the British to
this villain Kim cared okay well whoever
did it you've got no sympathy for Sergey
screep I'll have you I mean he's a
double agent if if kim Philby had been
killed by russian by sorry by british
agents when he defected to Russia
everyone in Britain would have said good
he's a double agent
well we're dealing just with effects you
know in our hands we have the two
Russian citizens Syrian Julius creep are
there Russian citizens they never left
the Russian citizenship
under the Vienna Convention were allowed
and we have the right to see them almost
a year past we didn't have a chance to
meet them the question is why have you
made requests who doesn't officially and
unofficially I was told in the foreign
offices that you will never see them but
they are Russian citizens do you feel
that after what happened a year ago that
the atmosphere relations are not thawing
between the United Kingdom and Russia I
would put this like in four layers if
you take politics we have three
difficult let's say questions the first
is Syria I mean I go chronically then of
course Ukraine and then Salisbury
so in this case of the Solebury we
expect the official results of the
investigation that we can check so
that's for us that's a must because we
were blamed this is first on so the
relations political relations they are
quite frozen as far as the economy
concern so the business is going is
doing well and in two years there was a
growth something like 40% and recently
top 10 British companies met President
Putin that was on the 20th of March and
basically we are satisfied with this
direction of the cooperation we have
good relations on education science and
of course culture so basically different
levels but still we need to improve the
political relations when Britain leaves
the European Union he must hear it
Britain is talking about striking
independent trade deals all around the
world would you like Russia to be one of
those countries to strike a strike okay
definitely
that was what would the subject that the
major British company discussed with the
President Putin and Russian business
we're open for cooperation it's not just
only with us but also with the Eurasian
Union this is the former republics of
the Soviet Union
so the market is 200 million people so
that's a great opportunity for Britain
and what you say to allegations
Russian interference in the referendum
campaign listeners a fake and Russian
interference in the American elections
it's also fake Robert Miller the special
counsel you will know has indicted well
he indicted them last year 13 Russian
citizens for interfering in the American
electoral process I want to read his
report because today
we don't have the text of the report and
as I understand the preliminary no
comments which were made just proved
that there was no there was no any
Russian meddling so this is just the
facts of life